el consejero del rey llamado arregla
está escuchando la plática entre tú el
rey y el pájaro y por un momento es
empiece sentir algo celoso pues se
supone que él es el hombre más sabio del
reino el más cercano consejero del rey
así que empieza a decir tú y ese pájaro
son inteligentes a ver díganme cómo
puedo atacar el problema de los precios
de las frutas y entonces juntes el rey
si esto es justo uno de los acertijos
que no hemos podido resolver el precio
de las frutas a ver arregla cuéntales el
acertijo del precio de las frutas por
favor entonces arregla dice bueno
nuestra intención es hacer un
seguimiento de cuánto cuesta el precio
de cada una de las frutas pero lo hemos
olvidado cuando veníamos de camino desde
el mercado lo que sí sabemos es cuánto
pagamos en total en el mercado cada vez
que fuimos y también sabemos cuánto
trajimos en total en cada ida hace una
semana cuando fuimos al mercado
compramos dos kilogramos de manzanas dos
kilogramos de manzanas y un kilogramo de
plátanos
un kilogramo de plátanos y pagamos en
aquella ocasión tres pesos en aquella
ocasión pagamos tres pesos salió barato
bueno una ocasión antes de eso nosotros
compramos seis kilogramos de manzanas
vamos a apuntar los seis kilogramos de
manzanas seis kilogramos de manzanas de
manzanas y tres kilogramos de plátanos y
compramos también tres kilogramos de
plátanos esa vez tenemos mucha hambre y
en total pagamos 15 pesos en total
pagamos 15 pesos así que al menos
sabemos que 6 kilogramos de manzanas y 3
kilogramos de plátanos en ese reino
cuestan 15 pesos así que el pájaro se te
queda viendo y después susurra al oído
del rey y el rey entonces dice lo
siguiente el pájaro me ha dicho bueno
podemos empezar definiendo variables por
aquí e intentemos resolverlo con álgebra
vamos a ver qué nos queda así que vamos
a empezar a definir variables voy a
decir no sé que a la letra minúscula va
a ser igual
vamos a decir que es igual a lo que
cuesta un kilogramo de manzanas un
kilogramos de manzanas ojo no es una
manzana es el costo las manzanas por un
kilogramo y vamos a decir que ven es lo
que cuesta los plátanos por kilogramo
por lo tanto esto nos va a ayudar a
poner esta información que tenemos aquí
en ecuaciones porque yo tengo que compré
en la primera ocasión dos kilogramos de
manzanas y un kilogramo de plátanos y
eso me costó tres pesos por lo tanto
esto en una ecuación me quedaría dos más
uno ven más ven porque no solamente me
estoy llevando dos kilogramos de
manzanas también estoy llevando el
kilogramo de plátanos por lo tanto 2a
más b es igual y en esa ocasión pagué
tres pesos por lo tanto esto va a ser
igual a lo que costó en total lo que
pague en total esa ves entonces 2 a más
b es igual a 3 ahora vamos con la
siguiente información con la información
que nos dieron la segunda vez que fui al
mercado yo tenía que 6 kilogramos de
manzanas
kilogramos de plátanos costaban 15 pesos
es decir 6 am + 3 b a esto le voy a
sumar 3 b y esto me va a dar 15 pesos 6
a + 3 b es igual a 15 pesos porque es lo
que pague en total ok ya tengo dos
ecuaciones y por lo tanto si yo quiero
saber la solución de estas dos
ecuaciones tengo varios métodos para
realizar lo que sume resta que
igualación qué método gráfico que
sustitución determinantes lo que sea
porque al final date cuenta que lo que
quiero es saber el precio o el costo de
un kilogramo de manzanas y de un
kilogramo de plátanos por lo tanto lo
que se me va a ocurrir es hacerlo por el
método de suma y resta así que voy a
agarrar la primera ecuación y la voy a
multiplicar toda por menos 3 porque la
idea que va detrás es pensar cuántas
veces cabe 6 en 2 am y te vas a dar
cuenta que cabe tres veces y entonces
como lo que quiero eliminar es la
variable
voy a multiplicar toda la primera
ecuación por menos 3 porque 2a por menos
3 me va a quedar menos 6 am y se va
poder cancelar voy a intentar eliminar
primero la am por lo tanto se multiplicó
todo por menos 3 me va a quedar menos 6
am - 3 pm es igual a menos 3 x menos 3
es decir menos nueve georges y usando la
suma resta lo primero que voy a hacer es
eliminar todo lo que se pueda eliminar
de estas dos ecuaciones así que déjenme
sumarlas a ver tengo seis a déjenme
poner al día en primero aquí está
y digo 6 am - 6 am 6 al menos 6 se van
3b - 3 b 3b - 3 b también se van o sea
que tiene que dar 0 y por el otro lado
me queda
15 - 9 15 menos 9 es lo mismo que 6
cuando 06 aquí hay algo muy raro se dan
cuenta esto parece no tener nada de
lógica cuando 0 es igual a 6 pues eso
nunca por lo tanto qué está pasando aquí
será magia negra esto o un invento de
los extraterrestres o vudú wow qué está
pasando aquí qué bizarro todas las
variables eliminaron así que volteas a
ver al pájaro pues parece ser que el
pájaro es la persona más inteligente
bueno no la persona más bien es el
vertebrado más inteligente de ese cuarto
y le preguntas qué pasa así que el
pájaro le susurra al oído del rey y el
rey dice que el pájaro le dijo lo
siguiente no hay solución y pueden
intentar graficar lo para ver qué está
pasando y se convenzan así que vamos a
graficar estas dos ecuaciones que yo
tengo aquí y para eso se me facilita más
ponerlo en la forma que tiene que ver
con la ordenada al origen así que voy a
agarrar la primera ecuación la cual es 2
a + b es igual a 3 y voy a despejar a b
para poderla graficar no olvides que en
esta ocasión no estoy graficando x
estoy graficando con a y bueno para
despejar a ver voy a pasar del otro lado
2 ahí me queda que b es igual a menos 2
a 3 perfecto esto es de la primera
ecuación ahora voy a despejar de la
segunda ecuación también a b para
poderla graficar en la segunda ecuación
yo tenía 6 a más 3 b es igual a 15 así
que primero voy a pasar del otro lado el
6 ahí va a pasar con signo negativo y
después voy a dividir todo entre 3 me va
a quedar que es igual a menos 2 a 6
entre 325 porque 15 entre 35 entonces
vamos a apuntar lo aquí la otra ecuación
es b es igual a menos 2 a más 5 así que
vamos a agarrar nuestros x coordinados
vamos a agarrar mi plano cartesiano y
vamos a graficar estas dos rectas que yo
tengo aquí entonces déjenme agarrar una
línea recta me voy a intentar que me
salga lo mejor posible para que no se
pierdan y vean que no está tan difícil
así que este va a ser mi primer eje me
va a ser mi eje de las veces lo estoy
tomando así porque ve es una función de
amd este va a ser mi eje de las as
vamos a empezar a ver 1 2 3 4 y 5
mi primer recta corta el eje de las
veces en 3 esta es mi ordenada el origen
y después de una pendiente de menos 2
aquí que es decir que me muevo hacia
abajo 2 y recordó 1 hacia la derecha y
ya tengo 2 puntos dado dos puntos existe
una recta que estoy intentando dibujar
lo mejor posible y solamente una recta
que pasa por ellos ahora voy a hacer lo
mismo para la segunda recta tiene como
ordenada el origen 5 corta por lo tanto
a mi eje de las veces en 5 positivo y
después bajamos 1 y nos movemos 1 a la
derecha y por lo tanto me da esta recta
que tengo aquí ya tengo mis dos rectas
graficadas y claro era de esperarse ya
se ven aquí que no hay ninguna solución
y la razón de por qué no hay ninguna
solución es porque estas dos rectas no
se intersectan no se intersectan y por
lo tanto no va a haber solución de este
problema y entonces date cuenta que el
pájaro tenía razón no hay ningún ave ni
ninguna a que cumplan simultáneamente
estas dos ecuaciones
y se nota porque mis rectas son
paralelas y es justo por eso que nos
daba que 0 es igual a 6 y por lo tanto
volteas a ver a regla y dentro de ti te
puedes pensar que te está tomando el
pelo por lo tanto le dices arregla aquí
hay algo raro me estás dando información
incompleta me estás dando a trabajar un
sistema de ecuaciones inconsistente que
te pasa o me estás dando malos datos o
algo está pasando puede ser que el
precio de las frutas haya cambiado o
simple y sencillamente me estás dando
mal los datos y por lo tanto no vas a
encontrar de mí una solución porque date
cuenta que dos rectas paralelas nunca se
intersectan no hay ningún punto en el
plano que esté simultáneamente en las
dos rectas paralelas 10 justo por eso
que no encuentra una y una vez que
satisfagan al mismo tiempo las dos
ecuaciones y entonces el pájaro voltea y
dice wow este 4 no tiene tan mal los
conceptos de álgebra